If you open a Bible to Matthew 2:16-18, you’ll
encounter one of the most notorious stories
in any religion.
Suspicious of a prophesy about a new king,
Herod the Great tricks the Magi into telling
him where baby Jesus was born, then sends
his soldiers to massacre every child under
the age of two in Bethlehem.
It’s a scene of shocking cruelty, one that
has ensured King Herod’s name is still synonymous
with evil today.
But what if we told you there was more to
Herod’s story?
Born in southern Palestine in 73 BC, Herod
was a man at the center of events that shaped
history.
He was there when Rome transformed from a
republic to an empire.
He consorted with Julius Caesar, befriended
Mark Antony, and submitted to the rule of
Augustus.
As king of Judea, he rebuilt the Second Temple,
saved the Olympic Games from bankruptcy, and
projected Jewish power across the world.
Yet he died an unloved tyrant, hated by his
people, his name forever stained with the
blood of the innocent.
This is the story of how one great man became
the tyrant king of history.
The Last Days of Judea
When Herod was born in 73 BC, it was a great
time to be from a Jewish family.
Roughly a hundred years before, a group of
priests known as the Maccabees had rebelled
against the Seleucid Empire and turned Jerusalem
into an independent city state.
For the first time in a long time, the Jews
were beholden to no-one.
That “no-one” included the superpower
of the era, the mighty Roman Republic, with
whose blessing Judea kept its independence.
Unfortunately for Herod, his family’s Jewish
roots weren’t as clear cut as he might have
liked.
The son of a wealthy, ambitious man known
as Antipater, Herod was by birth part Edomite,
part Arab.
Although his father’s family had been practicing
Jews for a century, they were still seen as
outsiders in Judea, a stigma that kept the
family from power.
But Herod’s pop Antipater was nothing if
not ambitious.
And there was no way he was going to let his
murky origins halt his family’s rise.
The year Herod turned six, Antipater got his
chance.
In 67 BC, Alexandra-Salome, the Queen of Judea,
died.
Unfortunately, she died without leaving a
clear line of succession, and her two sons
elected to take their claims to the battlefield.
And so began the first in a series of wars
that are gonna wrack Judea for the rest of
this video.
On one side was the Queen’s son Hyrcanus
II.
On the other was Hyrcanus’s brother Aristobulus.
Spoiler alert: you only need to remember Hyrcanus.
As the war got underway, Hyrcanus came to
Herod’s dad to beg for his support.
Antipater agreed, but not because he thought
Hyrcanus was in the right.
In their short meeting, Antipater realized
just how weak and easy to manipulate Hyrcanus
was.
And what could be better than having a weak,
manipulatable king on the throne who owes
you a favor?
By 63 BC, the war was moving decisively in
Hyrcanus’s favor.
Besieged in the Temple, Aristobulus was fast
running out of options.
Faced with the imminent collapse of his claim
to the throne, Aristobulus decided to roll
everything on a crazy gamble.
At the time, the Roman general Pompey was
riding around the eastern Mediterranean, conquering
everything in sight.
So Aristobulus bunged the general a massive
bribe to invade Judea on his behalf.
This would turn out to be a hilariously bad
move.
When word arrived, Pompey moved his army on
Jerusalem.
There he assessed the situation, came to the
conclusion Aristobulus was going to lose,
pocketed Aristobulus’s money and sided with
Hyrcanus to defeat him!
Amusing as this was, it was also a major historical
turning point.
In the wake of Aristobulus’s defeat, Pompey
annexed large parts of once-independent Judea.
He then installed the victorious Hyrcanus
on the throne as a Roman client king.
Just like that, the era of an independent
Jewish state came to a close.
In its place began an era of a Jerusalem under
the heel of Rome.
Not everyone was upset by this.
For Herod’s dad, Antipater, Pompey’s intervention
was like winning the lottery.
With Hyrcanus II in charge, Antipater began
happily cooperating with the new Roman authorities
and establishing himself as the real power
behind the throne.
Not that the population of Judea made this
easy.
In 57 BC, an anti-Roman uprising forced Hyrcanus
and Antipater to call the Roman Army back
to save their butts.
This time, Mark Antony answered the call.
Like Pompey before him, Mark Antony subdued
Jerusalem with ease.
In the aftermath of the campaign, he was introduced
to Antipater’s now 16-year old son.
Despite being ten years older than Herod,
Mark Antony hit it off with the boy.
Pretty soon, they were firm friends.
It was a friendship that would soon make Herod
the most-powerful man in Judea.
The Winds of Change
There’s a peculiar curse that afflicts small
states on the doorsteps of superpowers.
Each time the winds of change ripple through
the corridors of power, the smaller state
has to hunker down in case everything it holds
dear is blown away.
In Rome, in 53 BC, a hurricane was brewing.
For seven years, the Republic had been under
the sway of something called the First Triumvirate,
a collection of three great men, all hoping
to one day become undisputed ruler.
The first was Pompey, the old benefactor of
Antipater and Hyrcanus II.
The second was a man known as Crassus.
The third was Julius Caesar.
In May, 53 BC, Crassus died, ending the First
Triumvirate.
With the third part of their trio gone, it
could only be so long before Caesar and Pompey
turned on one another.
In January, 49 BC, they did.
The civil war that ripped through the Roman
Republic smashed apart old certainties everywhere.
In Judea, a presumably panicked Antipater
and Hyrcanus were forced to choose who to
throw their support behind: Pompey, the man
who had given them power; or Caesar, the man
Mark Antony now fought for?
In the end, Antipater went for Caesar.
It could have been a catastrophe, the first
step along a path that ended with the victorious
Pompey having Antipater’s entire family
crucified.
Instead, it became the making of them.
On August 9, 48 BC, Caesar annihilated Pompey’s
army at the Battle of Pharsalus.
Broken, Pompey ran, only to be assassinated
later that year.
In the aftermath, you better believe ol’
Julius didn’t forget who his friends were.
In 47 BC, Antipater was rewarded for ditching
Pompey by being made procurator (or financial
governor) of Judea.
Not only that, but he was given Roman citizenship,
something he was able to pass onto his son.
And Antipater had big plans for his new, citizen
son.
That same year, 47 BC, Antipater pulled some
strings and had the 26 year old Herod made
Governor of Galilee.
This was the first time the ancient world
got a good look at the sort of ruler Herod
would be.
The results were as shocking as you might
expect.
As Governor of Galilee, Herod’s first task
was to take care of some partisans who were
hiding out in caves, trying to overthrow the
Roman-backed state and calling themselves
the “new Maccabees”.
Everyone expected Herod to wage a conventional
war.
Instead, the new governor located the cave
system the rebels were hiding in, and sent
in soldiers with orders to massacre everyone.
It was a day of bloodshed so great that it
triggered riots in Jerusalem.
Herod was actually hauled before the religious
authorities and threatened with death for
his actions.
But Herod stood his ground.
Before the highest priests of Judaism, he
asserted his right as governor to deal with
rebels as he saw fit, including wholesale
murder.
Despite his brutality, Herod was let off free,
escaping the death penalty.
It was the first, major scandal he was implicated
in.
It wouldn’t be the last.
The Man who would be King
If the people of Judea were hoping the days
of political shockwaves from Rome battering
them senseless were over, events soon proved
otherwise.
Just three years after one civil war propelled
Herod and Antipater to the top, another came
along that threatened to destroy them.
On March 15, 44 BC, Julius Caesar was assassinated
in Rome by Brutus and Cassius.
The deed done, the two traitors fled to the
east of the Republic.
Back in the Eternal City, Mark Antony and
Caesar’s nephew Octavian declared a new
war to exterminate the assassins.
Unfortunately for Judea, this meant once again
being caught right in the middle of things.
From his new powerbase in the east, Cassius
ordered all provinces to pay for his war against
Mark Antony and Octavian.
That meant Judea coughing up 15,000kg of silver,
or its inhabitants being put to the sword.
As procurator, the job of collecting that
money fell to Antipater.
It’s possible to read Antipater’s willingness
to cooperate with Cassius as a way of protecting
Herod.
But, given what we know about Antipater’s
opportunism, it’s just as easy to imagine
he’d flipped his loyalties once again, like
a weasel playing Pogs.
The people of Judea certainly saw it as the
latter.
In 43 BC, one of Antipater’s own tax collectors
assassinated him.
When Herod got the news that his father had
been killed, he flew into a rage.
With permission from Cassius’s forces, he
tracked down the assassin and murdered him.
It could easily have been Herod’s last ever
act of violence.
In 42 BC, Mark Antony and Octavian – now
formed into the Second Triumvirate alongside
Marcus Aemilius Lepidus – defeated Cassius
and Brutus.
With the war over, Mark Antony went from warrior
to avenging angel, riding across the provinces
that had supported Cassius, leaving death
and destruction in his wake.
This should’ve been bad news for Herod,
who was suddenly stuck with explaining why
Antipater had leaped into bed with Cassius.
But Herod had apparently picked up a trick
or two from his old man.
He told the avenging angel “well of course
daddy had to support Cassius.
He’d have destroyed Judea if he didn’t.
But honestly, bro, we always wanted you to
win.”
How true this was is up for debate.
But Mark Antony trusted his old friendship
with Herod enough to buy it.
Rather than kill him, he made Herod tetrarch
of Galilee – it’s ruler.
And he made Herod’s brother tetrarch of
Jerusalem.
Suddenly, Hyrcanus II was reduced to a figurehead.
Real power in Judea now lay in the hands of
Antipater’s sons.
This turned out to be a hard sell for Judea’s
population.
Remember, Herod’s family were seen as not
really Jewish, but fake Jews who’d got in
bed with the hated Romans.
So when some dudes called the Parthians suddenly
attacked in 40 BC, most Jews decided to side
with them.
Amid the fighting, Hyrcanus II was put in
chains, had his ears sliced off, and was dragged
away to captivity in Babylon.
Herod’s brother, the tetrarch of Jerusalem,
committed suicide rather than face the same
fate.
Of the three rulers of Judea, only Herod escaped.
As the Parthians rampaged, he ran to the only
safe place he could think of: Rome.
In the Eternal City, Herod was forced to beg
the Second Triumvirate for help.
Mark Antony and Octavian listened and finally
agreed.
On one condition.
Herod would have to prove himself worthy by
retaking Jerusalem.
For the next three years, Herod led a Roman
army against the Parthian puppet government
ruling Judea.
The bitter civil war claimed many lives and
ruined Herod’s reputation further among
the Jewish population.
But it worked.
In 37 BC, Jerusalem fell and Herod rode into
the city.
Aged just 36, Herod had done it.
He’d taken back what was his, and proved
himself worthy to his Roman clients.
That same year, he had his highest honor yet
bestowed upon him.
No longer would Herod be merely tetrarch of
Galilee, ruling alongside another tetrarch
and a figurehead like Hyrcanus.
No, from this point on, there would be only
one title befitting a warrior like Herod.
He would be King of Judea.
Death of a Republic
Herod’s first few years on the throne were
spent trying to desperately apply a veneer
of legitimacy to his rule.
This meant divorcing his first wife, banishing
her from court, and remarrying a woman named
Mariamne, who just happened to be a princess
from the old ruling dynasty.
It also meant begging the now-defeated Parthians
to send Hyrcanus II back from Babylon.
This might seem an odd choice.
Hyrcanus was the only other guy around with
a legitimate claim to Herod’s throne.
Unfortunately for Herod, though, the captured
king was still popular in Judea.
So Herod arranged to have Hyrcanus brought
back and treated with the utmost respect – on
the unspoken condition that Hyrcanus go around
being all like “Gee, this Herod sure is
a great king.
We should probably do what he says.”
This done, Herod went about winning over the
populace.
Over the next five years, he built massive
new city walls for Jerusalem, and a brand
new citadel to protect the Temple – named
Antonia, after Mark Antony, naturally.
He even had coins minted showing himself alongside
traditional Jewish objects, just to hammer
home the point that he really was a Jewish
king.
But, as we’ve already seen time and again
in this video, the fate of Judean rulers wasn’t
decided in Judea itself, but in Rome.
And Rome was already gearing up for yet another
civil war.
In 33 BC, the Second Triumvirate went the
way of the First Triumvirate and unceremoniously
collapsed.
Two years after that, in 31 BC, Octavian and
Mark Antony decided to fight each other to
the death.
For Herod, this was the first time he’d
found himself caught between two Roman factions
without Antipater around.
This was a problem, because Herod lacked Antipater’s
wily political instincts.
While his father had been happy to chuck old
allies like Pompey and Caesar when he thought
the winds were blowing against them, Herod
was just too loyal to his friends.
As the armies of Octavian and Antony gathered,
Herod threw in his lot with Antony.
You can probably guess where this is going.
On September 2, 31 BC, Octavian demolished
Antony’s forces at the Battle of Actium.
Antony was forced to flee into hiding, where
he and Cleopatra committed suicide.
At the same time, a summons landed on Herod’s
desk, calling him to Rhodes to explain himself
to Octavian.
If you’ve ever had to go before your boss
after making some colossal mistake, you may
have the faintest inkling of what Herod was
feeling on that long and lonely boat ride.
Unlike when he had to explain Antipater’s
actions to Mark Antony, Herod had no friendship
with Octavian he could fall back on.
Worse, as a guy who had literally named citadels
after the defeated Antony, Herod was intimately
connected to Octavian’s enemy.
Perhaps it says something of Herod’s state
of mind that his last act before leaving Judea
was to execute Hyrcanus II.
That way, if he Herod was executed in turn,
at least the throne would stay in his family.
But it turned out Herod really could be as
wily as Antipater.
Once in Rhodes, Herod didn’t even bother
trying to lie.
He boldly told Octavian that he had supported
Mark Antony to the death, that he’d been
loyal to the general for decades, and would
remain loyal even now.
Octavian listened and, when Herod was done,
presumably gave a wry smile, before saying
that Herod’s loyalty was a far more useful
asset to Rome than someone who would try and
worm their way out of trouble.
He then reconfirmed Herod as King of Judea.
It’s hard to imagine what must have been
going through Herod’s mind on the boat ride
home.
Against all the odds, his truth-telling gamble
had paid off.
Octavian might not exactly trust him, but
he certainly respected him.
And in Octavian’s good books was exactly
where the King of Judea wanted to be.
Some three years after the meeting in Rhodes,
Octavian finally completed his takeover of
the Roman Republic.
He took the name history now knows him by:
Augustus.
After a half century of bloodshed, Rome’s
transformation into an Empire was finally
complete.
The Good King
With the drama of the Empire’s creation
out of the way, Herod was able to finally
settle into actually ruling Judea.
Between 27 and 20 BC, he built up an image
as a sort of Pagan Jewish ruler, one he hoped
would appeal both to Judea’s population
and his Roman backers.
But if neither side was ever really convinced
by Herod’s posing, they couldn’t ignore
his material achievements.
As King of Judea, Herod spent his time building
new stuff like a cocaine-addicted Bob the
Builder.
Jerusalem got a new amphitheater, market,
royal palace, and a ton of new homes to replace
those destroyed by an earthquake.
New aqueducts brought fresh water into the
city.
On the fringes of Judea, huge new fortresses
were built to protect the kingdom.
Some of these, such as Masada, are still extant
and still impressive.
Then there was the money spent abroad, shoring
up Judea’s image.
Iconic cities like Damascus and Beirut were
given Herod-sponsored makeovers.
When the Olympic Games threatened to go bankrupt,
Herod stepped in and saved it.
This largesse was accompanied by an unmistakable
increase in Judean power.
Augustus twice visited Herod in Jerusalem,
and each time he handed over new land to the
king.
By 20 BC, Judea had expanded to include swathes
of modern Syria, Lebanon, and Jordan.
As Judea’s prestige grew, those in Rome
took notice.
Soon Jerusalem was flooded with Roman playwrights,
historians, and philosophers, all eager to
see the booming city state.
And you better believe Herod tried to use
this power for good.
He was a vocal defender of Jews living in
other states, often going out of his way to
appease their Gentile hosts.
But of course this is still Herod we’re
talking about.
Underneath all this glitz and glamor lurked
a dark side.
On the streets, ordinary Judeans were suffering
enormous tax burdens to pay for Herod’s
projects.
On top of that, there were uneasy questions
hovering over Herod’s Jewishness.
With his fondness for pagan, Roman things,
many in Jerusalem believed their ruler was
trying to stealthily sabotage their culture.
Not that it was all bad for ordinary men and
women.
During the horrific famine of 25 – 24 BC,
it was Herod’s Roman contacts that stopped
the disaster by arranging huge shipments of
grain to Judea.
But it wasn’t until 20 BC that Herod’s
made his greatest attempt to win Jewish hearts.
He decided to rebuild the Second Temple.
Way back in 519 BC, the Neo-Babylonians had
destroyed the First Temple.
A replacement had since been built, but it
was the very definition of “modest”.
Under Herod, that was about to change.
Everything you think of when you think of
Jerusalem’s Temple was a result of Herod’s
construction spree.
The sweeping walls, vast towers, and great
courtyard covering the Temple Mount all came
into being because of Herod.
The famous Western Wall you can still see
standing today?
That’s another Herod project.
Not that this grand new Temple mollified everyone.
Herod kitted it out with too many Roman touches,
too many architectural nods to Judea’s imperial
overlords.
Nor did he take criticism kindly.
When a small sect of radical Jews tore down
a Roman eagle symbol from the new Temple,
Herod had them all burned alive.
Still, as Herod entered the last decade of
his life in 14 BC, the signs were all there
that he might go down in history as a not
so bad ruler.
That he might even live up to his billing
of Herod the Great.
But you and I both know that there’s one
more act to come.
The Massacre of the Innocents
One of the fascinating things about Herod
is that, despite still being a household name
2,000 years later, he often feels like he
was only ever a bit player in two major stories.
For most of his life, the story Herod appeared
in was the epic novel The Rise of the Roman
Empire.
But, as he entered his old age, the King of
Judea found himself cast as the villain in
an even more famous tale.
That’s right, it’s time for us to talk
about Jesus.
There’s a long-running debate about Christ’s
exact birthdate, with anywhere from 6 BC to
4 BC being generally accepted.
Whichever is true, by the time Christ was
born, Herod’s rule was in a very bad place.
The trouble had really started in 10 BC, when
Herod had waged war against the Nabateans
and so screwed up the campaign that he’d
fallen from Augustus’s favor.
This sudden demotion in status seems to have
triggered a crisis of paranoia in the king.
Convinced supporters of the dead Hyrcanus
II were plotting in the shadows, Herod began
a ruthless campaign to root out suspected
enemies.
He’d already put his wife Mariamne to death,
but now he also had her brother, mother, grandfather
and children all killed.
Herod even had two of his own sons, Antipater
and Aristobulus, executed.
When Augustus heard, he joked it would be
safer to be Herod’s pet pig than one of
his sons.
Nor were those outside Herod’s court safe.
In his last years, Herod had hundreds of ordinary
Judeans thrown in dungeons and tortured.
He masterminded gruesome public executions
to keep order.
Rumors started to swirl that he had defiled
the tombs of David and Solomon.
That he’d taken nine wives, in defiance
of Jewish customs.
Although there were still triumphs – such
as the opening of Herod’s great new port
city of Caesarea in 9 BC – they were overshadowed
by a cloud of paranoia hanging over Judea.
It wasn’t helped by a horrific illness the
king contracted that ate away at his flesh,
thought today to have been Fournier's gangrene.
The disease left Herod so mad that he gave
insane orders, from the mass execution of
300 soldiers to a demand that all the Judean
nobles be dragged to an amphitheater on his
death and shot full of arrows.
It was against this dark background that a
sect of Jewish scholars suddenly announced
the time of the Messiah was almost upon them.
And so we come to Herod’s most infamous
legacy.
Matthew 2:16-18 tells us that Herod became
worried about the prophesized Messiah, eventually
ordering every child under two in Bethlehem
put to death.
Known as the Massacre of the Innocents, the
killing is controversial among historians
today because it only appears in Matthew’s
gospel.
The other gospels don’t mention it, nor
do the accounts of Josephus or Nicolaus of
Damascus.
Still, from what we know of Herod’s mental
state in his last years, having a bunch of
random babies killed would’ve been completely
in character.
Thankfully, the massacre would be the last
awful thing the King of Judea ever did.
In 4 BC Herod the Great finally passed away
in Jericho, only a handful of months after
a failed suicide attempt.
Traditionally, it’s thought he died in March,
although no-one really knows for sure.
After his passing, Augustus decreed Judea
would be split into three parts.
The kingdom Herod had helped create was no
more.
In the end, the life of Herod was defined
less by who he was than by those who were
around him.
The lives of Julius Caesar, Mark Antony, Augustus
and, of course, Jesus continue to fascinate
us even now, two millennia later.
To have been a part of all their stories is
a remarkable achievement in itself, even if
Herod may not have seen it that way.
The poem Ozymandias by Percy Shelley tells
of a traveler who finds a great, broken statue
of some king in the middle of a desert.
Although the statue’s pedestal declares
“Look on my works, ye mighty, and despair!”
there is nothing left of this dead king’s
deeds.
No hints of his life.
Just endless sand.
In the desert of history, it’s tempting
to think the same has come of Herod, with
his name still only just about visible thanks
to a single verse in a single book of the
Bible.
But, as this video has hopefully shown, there
was more to the life of Herod than one horrific
act.
He may not have been a good man, or even a
particularly clever man, but Herod the Great
was certainly one thing.
He was a man worth remembering.